Bitte schön.
Guten Tag.
Hallo.
Hallo, setzen Sie sich bitte.
Ich heiße Foukambarra und bin auf dieser Station als Dienstabenderarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Gespräch führen.
Wenn Sie damit einfallen, können wir anfangen.
Ja, bin ich.
Als Erster werde ich ein paar Argemeinfragen stellen.
Also, wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Petra Elias.
Petra Elias.
Ich bin eine Frau.
Können Sie Ihre Nachname buchstabieren?
Ja, E-H-L-E-R-S-E-L-S.
Elias.
Okay, Frau Elias.
Wie alt sind Sie?
52.
Wann wurden Sie gebogen?
17. März 1971.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
84 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Elias?
1,67 m.
Haben Sie einen Hausarzt oder einen Hausarzt?
Ja, Dr. Lindemann.
Wie viel Lindemann, ich glaube?
Lindemann, ja.
Und was möchten Sie noch wissen?
Was hat Sie sonst geführt?
Ich habe seit ca. 5 Stunden ziemlich starke Bauchschmerzen.
Die werden auch schlimmer.
Mir ist übel, ich habe 3-mal erbrochen.
Das geht mir nicht gut.
Und können Sie seit 5 Stunden eine Bauchschmerzen haben?
Können Sie es zeigen, wo genau sind die Schmerzen?
Das ist mehr so rechts unter den Rippen, so am Oberbauch rechts.
Direkt oben auch.
Okay.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wenn 1 leichte und 10 unerträgliche Schmerzen sind?
Das wechselt so, weil es kommt und geht mal.
Also ich würde sagen zwischen 6 und 9.
6 und 9.
Und können Sie diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Also eine Po-Hände oder Stich-Hände?
Schmerzen.
Mehr stechend.
So ähnlich, ich habe es noch nie gehabt, wie eine Kolik.
Ja, eine Kolik.
Okay, gibt es etwas, was diese Schmerzen verstärkt oder in der Erz?
Wenn ich so eine Kolik habe, dann muss ich mich hinsetzen
und so nach vorne rüber beugen.
Dann wird es vielleicht etwas leichter, aber nicht viel.
Aber ansonsten muss ich mich ganz ruhig verhalten.
Okay.
Und Frau Ehlers, Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie haben 3 Mal Air Brokschen, oder?
Ja.
Haben Sie Durchefall oder Verstopfung?
Nein, Durchefall habe ich nicht.
Ich habe normalerweise regelmäßig Stuhlgange einmal am Tag.
Zuletzt war das, glaube ich, so vor 12 Stunden.
Und wie sah Ihr Air Brokschen aus?
Also gelblich oder schleimig?
Also gelblich, schleimig, ja.
Okay.
Und sind Ihnen eine Aufstoßen- oder Zotbrennen aufgefallen?
Nein, Zotbrennen habe ich nicht.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn mir so übel ist, ich habe 3 Mal Air Brochen,
dann habe ich jetzt auch immer wieder so ein Würgereiz.
Und stradeln diese Schmerzen in andere Körperregionen aus?
Ja, ein bisschen in die rechte Schulter habe ich den Eindruck.
Ja, in die rechte Schulter.
Haben Sie schon einmal diese Beschwerden?
Hatten Sie schon einmal diese Beschwerden?
Das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Waren Sie deswegen beim anderen Arzt?
Nein, ich war ja jetzt erst seit 5 Stunden.
Ja, mein Hausarzt sagte, ich habe Galensteine.
Er hat er festgestellt vor 1,5 Jahren.
Und hat aber gesagt, solange die jetzt keine Beschwerden machen,
muss man die nicht operieren.
Wann hat Ihr Hausarzt das gesagt?
Ja, vor ungefähr 1,5 Jahren.
1,5 Jahre, oder?
1,5 Jahre.
Okay, Sie haben keine Durchfall.
Sie haben keine Peristuppwund, sagt man Sie mir.
Okay, haben Sie noch etwas bemerkt?
Also möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, mir ist ein bisschen schwindelig.
Ich habe auch, wenn der Schmerz da ist,
habe ich Schweißausbrüche.
Okay, wie ist der Appetit, Frau Ileis?
Normalerweise ist er sehr gut.
Ich habe in den letzten Jahren immer zugenommen.
Er ist eigentlich zu gut.
Aber seit ich die Schmerzen habe, habe ich keinen Appetit.
Da habe ich auch nichts gegessen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Wasser lassen?
Nein, normalerweise nicht.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich glaube nicht.
Das würde ich merken, ich habe keinen Fieber.
Ich habe einen Schweißausbrüche.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu zugenommen?
Sie haben schon gesagt, aber...
Er zugenommen, abgenommen auf keinen Fall.
Ich möchte gerne abnehmen, aber ich habe immer so viel Hunger.
Ich muss immer so viel essen.
Und wie viel Kilogramm in welcher Zeitraum haben Sie zu genommen?
So in den letzten Jahren, so 2,5-3 Kilo.
Wie ist Ihr Durst? Trinken Sie regelmäßig?
Ich trinke normalen Mineralwasser oder morgens Kaffee.
Ich trinke auch nochmal Tee.
Und Sie leiden Sie an Irgendwäsche für Erkrankungen?
Außer Kalensteine?
Was meinten Sie mit Vorerkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit.
Ach so, ja, ja, habe ich.
Ich habe hohe Blutdruck.
Seit 10 Jahren.
Und da nehme ich auch Medikamente ein.
Dann habe ich auch hohe Blutfettwerte.
Ich habe so ungefähr seit 7 Jahren.
Da nehme ich auch eine Tablette.
Und ich habe jetzt seit 2 Jahren, hat der Hausarzt mir auch
Zucker-Tablette aufgeschrieben, weil ich jetzt auch ein Zucker habe.
Er sagt, das kommt von hohem Gewicht, von zu vielen Essen.
Und weil ich mich zu wenig bewege.
Ja, ich verstehe, Sie sind ganz genau.
Und welche Medikamente nehmen Sie ein?
Ich habe hier ein Zestasier auf.
Bei dem Blutdruck nehme ich Kandisatan.
4 Milligramm, eine Morgens und eine Abends.
Dann nehme ich Metformin, 850, eine halbe Morgens
und eine ganze Abends.
Dann nehme ich noch gegen Cholesterin,
dann nehme ich Rosu-Vastatin, das 10 steht dahinter.
Dann nehme ich eine Tablette abends.
10 Milligramm oder?
Und wurden Sie schon einmal operiert oder stationär behandelt?
Ich wurde als Kind operiert, soweit ich mich erinnern kann.
Da hatte ich einmal einen Leistenbruch.
Auf der linken Seite, da war ich glaube ich 11 Jahre alt.
Und dann wurde ich auch an den Mandeln operiert.
Da war ich 8 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wie ist die Impfstatus?
Sind Sie gegen Corona und gegen Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, da bin ich geimpft.
Ich war jetzt gerade vor einem halben Jahr
beim Hausarzt zur Untersuchung.
Und ich war es gezeigt und er sagte,
da bin ich erstmal gut versorgt.
Und waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Letzter Zeit, was verstehen Sie unter letzter Zeit?
Ja, in den nächsten 6 Monaten.
Nein, war ich nicht im Ausland.
Okay.
Und Frau Öl, ich möchte noch mal fragen,
haben Sie etwas bemerkt, also ein Hautausschlag
oder ein Hautperfarbung?
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt oder?
Nein, da habe ich nichts bemerkt.
Vor einem halben Jahr hat mich der Hausarzt auch untersucht.
Hat die Hunde besucht und fand da nichts Auffälliges.
Und ich merke auch nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Und ich vermerke, Sie haben keine Husten oder?
Husten habe ich nicht.
Obwohl ich rauche.
Haben Sie allergien oder Unkerträglichkeiten?
Nein, ist mir nicht bekannt.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie rauchen.
Also, was rauchen Sie?
Zigaretten.
Ungefähr 10 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 30 Jahren.
Seit 30 Jahren.
Aber Sie sollen dieses Zigaretten-Konsum verliehen.
Also, wenn Sie Hilfe brauchen, können Sie mir sagen,
wir haben hier einen Spezialist, der Ihnen helfen kann.
Ja, das sagen mir meine Kinder auch immer, mein Mann.
Aber es fällt mir schwer.
Ja, ich weiß es.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Freilässt.
Vielleicht pro Woche, vielleicht zwei Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Und ich muss eine unangenehme Frage stellen, Freilässt.
Bitte nehmen Sie das nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine özionämäßige Frage.
Also, haben Sie schon einmal Drogen probiert,
oder konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Ja, da war ich aber ganz jung.
Da war ich 20 Jahre alt.
Da habe ich mal Cannabis geraucht.
Einmal oder?
302 Mal, aber nicht mehr.
Ist mir nicht gut bekommen.
Das ist eine gute Entscheidung.
Das ist Verlassennaschen.
Okay, und tragen Sie Sport?
Nein, leider nicht.
Ich habe ein bisschen Probleme mit den Knien.
Und mit der Hüfte, meine Arzt sagt, ich bin auch zu schwer.
Der Körper muss zu viel Gewicht tragen.
Und ich mache keinen Sport.
Das ist keine krankhafte Fettleibigkeit.
Sie können einfach Gewichtsabnahme abnehmen.
Ja, aber es fällt mir schwer.
Ich habe immer so viel Appetit.
Ich kann immer so gerne essen.
Es fällt mir so schwer, Gewicht abzunehmen.
Freilässt, ich wollte wieder fragen,
wenn Sie Fettiges essen,
wenn Sie Schmerzen haben?
Ich habe Schmerzen.
Seitdem ich Schmerzen habe, habe ich in den letzten 5 Stunden
nichts mehr Appetit.
Es gibt etwas aus der Zeit,
dass Sie beim Ermitteln haben.
Was hatten Sie gemacht, wenn Sie Schmerzen aufgetriegt haben?
Auf einem Geburtstag habe ich 2 Sahnetorte gegessen.
Sahnekuchen.
Vielleicht kann es damit zu tun haben.
Sie sind verheiratet.
Sie haben Kinder.
Sie sind 20 und 22 Jahre alt.
Sie sind 20 Jahre alt.
Sie wohnen nicht mehr bei uns.
Sie sind ausgezogen und leben woanders.
Sie sind gesund.
Was machen Sie als Beruflich?
Ich bin Verwaltungsangestellter.
Haben Sie viel Stress?
Nein.
Freilässt, ernähren Sie sich ausgewogen?
Ausgleichen.
Ernähren?
Nein.
Meine Kinder sagen immer zu mir,
ich würde zu viel essen.
Zu viel Kalorien.
Manchmal zu süß.
Zu viel Fleisch.
Da ist noch etwas, was ich ändern muss.
Das habe ich mir vorgenommen.
Aber ich habe es noch nicht umgesetzt.
Sie leben hier?
Ja.
Der Vater ist 79 Jahre alt.
Er hat auch Zucker.
Er hat hohe Blutdruck.
Er hat hohe Ahnsäure.
Er hat auch schon mehrfach Giftanfälle.
Mutter ist 77 Jahre alt.
Sie leidet unter
Knorrenschwund.
Sie hatte schon mehrfach
Knorrenbrüche durch Stürze,
Wirbelbruch.
Er hat den Unterarm gebrochen.
Er musste auch Medikamente für einnehmen.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Eine Schwester, die ist 2 Jahre älter als ich.
Die wurde vor einem Jahr an der Galenblase operiert.
Weil sie Galensteine hatte.
Und die auch ihr Probleme bereitet haben.
Ja, okay.
Gibt es etwas, was die
hinfügen möchte?
Da haben Sie Fragen.
Ja, ich frage mich, was kann das sein?
Dass ich so heftige Schmerzen habe.
Ich möchte gerne, dass ich die Schmerzen auch bald los werde.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Symptomen
gehe ich von
eine Gehege von Kohlelitischmerzen.
Was heißt das?
Also Galenblase.
Aber das ist nur eine Verdachtdiagnose.
Also ich muss als Erster
eine Schmerzschmerzschmerzschmerzschmerzen machen.
Sie die Verpälschung untersuchen
und eine Nombulat abnehmen.
Danach werde ich ein
Bauchultraschall und Röntgen veranlassen.
Und eventuell können wir
ein ERCP durchführen.
Also außer dem
soll ich mit meinem Oberarzt über Ihren Fall sprechen.
Aber machen Sie keine Sorgen.
Ich werde Sie gleichzeitig informieren.
Okay, gut.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Guten Abend Frau Alres.
Wann haben Sie Ihre Frauenarzt besucht?
Das war vielleicht vor
4 Monaten.
Da gehe ich einmal im Jahr hin.
Aber der Frauenarzt, die Gynäkologe war zufrieden.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie 3 Mal erbrochen haben.
Wie sieht Ihre Erbrochenen aus?
Ja, so gelblich schleinig.
Gelblich schleinig.
Ah, okay.
Und ist die Farbe Ihres Stuhl
oder Ihres Öhrin verändert?
Also seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe, hatte ich noch keinen Stuhlgang.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen.
Beim Urin habe ich jetzt nicht darauf geachtet.
Ich habe allerdings auch wenig Wasser gelassen.
Weil ich in den letzten 5 Stunden, wo es mir so schlecht ging,
habe ich zwar etwas getrunken, aber nicht so viel.
Und da war ich glaube ich nur einmal auf Toiletten.
Ich habe es nicht so viel getrunken.
Ich habe hin und wieder auch sonst Blähungen.
Aber nicht jetzt.
Die machen mir eigentlich keine großen Beschwerden.
Vielen Dank.
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen ein?
Gegen Blähungen?
Ja, ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es nicht.
Gegen Blähungen?
Nehmen Sie etwas dagegen ein?
Nein, so stark sind die nicht.
Ich trinke dann hin und wieder mal
einen Fenchel Anis Kümmeltee.
Und der tut mir ganz gut.
Ich habe den Eindruck.
Aber ich nehme sonst keine Medikamente dagegen ein.
Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe wieder etwas dagegen ein.
Aber ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe es nicht.
Ich habe immer mit meinen Kollegen.
Weln informiert.
Die Schmerz Intensität liege auf der Enferse bei 6 bis 9 von Sein.
Die Schmerz im Gurten in der Rechten Schulter ausstrahlen.
Der Schmerz wurde akut 10 Gurren in Ruhe ausgelöst.
Die Schmerz sind der Patienten folgende Symptome aufgefallen.
Persistieren der Neusea seit 5 Stunden.
Imesis 3 Mal gelblich schleimig, Brechreis, Schweißausbühle und Vertigo.
Aufgesilten Nachfragen wurden der Patient Fiba,
Gasuintestinelle Störung und Urinnelstörung verneint.
Der Schmerz strahlt.
Die Patientin gibt eine Ausstrahlung.
Der Schmerz ist in die rechte Schulter an.
Ja, ich habe schon gesagt, die Schmerz im Gurten in der Rechte Schulter ausstrahlen.
Ach so, alles klar. Gut.
Gut. Einverstanden.
Vulkan.
An vorer Krankenkern leidet sie an Kohlili-Giasis.
Wollen Sie vielleicht von Anfang an?
Ja.
Hallo, Herr Weber-Arts.
Ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurz seit?
Ja.
Frau Petra Helers ist ein 52-jähriger Patientin.
Die hat sich heute seit 5 Stunden erst mal aufgetreten.
Sie hat eine hohe Kollikartige.
Sie hat eine Ausstrahlung in der Rechte Schulter.
Rechte Schulter, ja.
Sie fügt dahinten zu, dass die Schmerzen 6 bis 9 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala zahlen.
Im Laufe der Zeit ist sie nicht mehr geworden.
Frau Helers berichtete, dass die Schmerzen beim Beugen verbessert, sich verbessert hätten.
Vernehr sind der Patientin die folgende Begleitsymptome aufgefallen.
Ein Amasis 3-mal geblischleimig sich aus.
Wir haben eine Rucola, Flutulens, und Namusea.
Die Vegetative an einem Nase sei ist nachfällig bis auf eine Schwindig,
Schweißausbrüche, Schmerzbedingte, Inapetens.
Die Fragen nach Wasserlasten, Mixionprobleme, Fieber, Kreksi,
Sie haben eine Corelithiasis, ihre Hausarzt sage das, seit 1,5 Jahren.
Also, wie der Patientin ist eine Corelithiasis seit 1,5 Jahren bekannt.
Bekannt. Ja, bekannt.
Und Arterlihypertoni, also sie leide an Arterlihypertoni seit 10 Jahren.
Hyperfolesterin Nemi seit 7 Jahren und die wird es mehlitus tip 2 seit 2 Jahren.
Es wurde bei ihr als Kind mit 11 Jahren linksseitige Inguinalherneektomie und mit 8 Jahren eine Tonzelektomie durchgeführt.
Ja, eine linksseitige Herneektomie mit Herneektomie.
Und in Besuch auf die Medikation nehme Frau Ehlers, die vorgehende Medikamente ein, regelmäßig ein,
Kandisartan 4 mg, Morgen und Abends 1 Tablette, mit Formen 850 mg, Halbtablette Morgen, 1 Tablette Abend.
Und Rosovastatin 10 mg, Noa Abends 1 Tablette.
Im Status sei verständig und bei der Reise an Emnesen fandens ich keine Reise.
Sie habe keine Allergien und Unverträglichkeiten und sie rauhe seit 30 Jahren, sind cigarette-enträglich, also 30, 30 Jahren.
Und trinke Provohe 2 mit 2 Gläser Wein.
Außerdem habe sie mit 20 Jahren ein oder 2 Mal Cannabis probiert und sie treiben keine Sport.
Frau Ehlers sei verheiratet und habe 2 gesunde Tochter, die 27 und 22 Jahre alt sind.
Und sie sei ein Verwaltungsangestellter vom Beruf.
Ihre Mutter sei 27 Jahre alt.
77 Jahre alt.
Und sie hatte Ostiprose und viele verschiedene, sie leide an Ostiprose und habe viele verschiedene Frakturen gehabt.
Sie leidet an frakturierender Ostiprose.
Der Mutter besteht wohl eine frakturierende Ostiprose.
Ihr Vater ist 79 Jahre alt und er hatte Diabetes mellitus, Arteri Hepatoni und Arthritis Ulica.
Außerdem habe sie eine Schwester, die 54 Jahre alt ist und auch Polythiasis hat.
Ja, die Schwester wurde vor 2 Jahren chulizistektumiert.
Ja, eine Schwester vor 2 Jahren eine chulizistektumie.
Das ist schon mal eine Maloperiasis.
Bei chulizistikumier, bei symptomatischer chulizistikumier.
Aufgrund der erwähnten Symptomen gehe ich von chulitis aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen die Folgenden im Beitrag.
Ich habe eine Pancreatitis, Apprentisitis, Rolitis und ectopische Schwangerschaft.
Als nächstes würde ich diese Patienten körperlich unterzunehmen.
Ich schaue, ich würde die Diabetes oder Hautverfarbung anschauen.
Ich palpiere die Diabetes, während der Stärke einatmet,
taste ich unter dem rechten Dipum, wenn die Einatmung sistiert ist,
dann können wir die Diabetes positiv sagen.
Bei der Labo würde ich CHP, BSG, ALT, ASD, Alkalitia Phosphatase,
Gamagulatamin Transparase, Beta-HCG, Bilirubin und Urin-Test.
Das ist sehr ausführlich. Wichtig ist mir, wenn Sie den Patienten vorstellen,
dass sie die Anamnese gut schildern, dass sie ihre Verdachtstiagnose schildern
mit den medizinischen Ausdrücken.
Sie brauchen gar nicht, vielleicht zu sagen,
welche Technik der Untersuchung sie anwenden.
Wichtig ist, glaube ich, dass Sie sagen, ich werde die Patientin
zunächst körperlich untersuchen, diesen Labor abnehmen
und eine vielleicht Oberbauchsonographie machen
und die Patientin, pharentral, die Patientin bleibt nüchter.
Nichts mehr um alles zu führen lassen, auch für die Dörster,
dass sie nichts mehr trinkt und auch nichts mehr ist.
Ihre Differenzialdiagnose, ich teile die Verdachtstiagnose
einer symptomatischen Choleletiersis mit glückartigen Schmerz
und differenzialdiagnostisch, sicherlich Begleitpankreatitis,
muss man in Betracht ziehen, eventuell ein Ulcus duudini
für die Qualisation herdurch aus da sein kann.
Eine Apendicitis ist immer ein Thema, dagegen spricht
so ein bisschen für mich die Ausstrahlung in die rechte Schulter.
Eine bekannte Anamnese der Choleletiersis, kein Fieber,
aber man sollte es auf alle Fälle natürlich mit untersuchen,
das ist ganz klar.
Gut, ich finde, das haben Sie sehr systematisch und ruhig gemacht.
Sie haben sich nicht ablenken lassen, wenn ich zwischendurch sage,
ich rauche und ich habe keinen Husten, obwohl ich rauche,
das haben Sie sich gemerkt, aber Sie haben nicht gleich das Rauchen
angeführt, weil Sie erst mal Ihr Anamnese-Schema
abgearbeitet haben.
Das finde ich sehr gut und Sie haben es auch, finde ich,
gut umgesetzt in der Vorstellung mit den erforderlichen Fachausdrücken.
Die haben Sie, denke ich, alle benannt, das fand ich sehr gut
und haben sich auch bemüht, nicht zu lange Sätze zu sprechen,
lieber zwei kürzere Sätze als einen sehr langen.
Das ist immer im Gestrüpp der deutschen Grammatik schwierig,
auch für mich, einfach nur aus taktischen Gründen,
lieber zwei kurze Sätze sagen.
Manchmal müssen Sie aufpassen, wenn Sie sagen, die Patientin sei
oder war, wo ich auch sagen, die Patientin berichtet,
also aktuell ja, sie berichtet, über akute, seit fünf Stunden,
circa fünf Stunden bestehende abdominelle Schmerzen
mit zunehmender Tendenz, zunehmender Schmerzintensität,
das ist die Gegenwart, also sie berichtet jetzt.
Sie berichtet, t klingt immer, das war vielleicht gestern,
dass sie mir das berichtet hat, sondern sie sitzt jetzt ja hier
in der Notfallaufnahme bei Ihnen.
Ja, aber ich bin damit einverstanden.
Das haben Sie gut gemacht und jetzt üben Sie noch ein paar Wochen
und dann machen Sie in Stuttgart die Prüfung.
Ja, gerne.
Oder hat der Moderator noch etwas zu ergänzen?